foreign
and identity politics
I would like to start with what happened
in the United States last summer because
the book came out a year before the
riots and protests in the U.S and I
could not help but feel as if they
Vindicated the thesis of the book
because the book argues that in the
absence of religion in the absence of
family in the absence of what throughout
human history have been very Primal
attachments for all human beings
in the absence of those things as those
things weaken Across the Western World
we see an increasingly impassioned
flight to Identity politics to
Collective identities and the reason for
that flight is that you know fundamental
to all of us is the question who am I
and if you were to ask me who am I
would probably say something like I'm a
mother I'm a Catholic I'm an aunt I'm a
wife Etc in other words my intuitive
response would be to Define Myself by my
Primal attachments what we have to
understand is that in this day and age a
lot of people do not have strong
attachments of that nature we live in
societies that are secularizing rapidly
so that takes one answer off the table
who am I I'm a Child of God
a lot of people wouldn't say that
wouldn't think to say that don't believe
that
but then we get into the more
complicated tangle of defining oneself
by relations to one's family and let me
say at the outset there's not a family
in the world that is not affected by the
trends that we are describing We're All
in This Together
so when I talk about something like uh
say divorce and remarriage and what that
does to The Sibling uh relationships of
people with half-brothers Step Brothers
Etc
I I'm coming from a place where I know
as much about this as you do which is
that it's it's ubiquitous
but what these more attenuated
relationships have done over time is
weaken the emotional uh attachments of
people they've weakened the
gravitational pull that people feel
toward their families and we're not
talking about Ozzie and Harriet you know
perfect nuclear family we're talking
about the extended family which for most
of us has shrunk by quite a lot
so I get into this in Primal screams for
a couple of reasons one is that I really
do believe that in the rise in mental
health problems in the increasing acting
out that we see on campuses uh people
duct taping their mouths shot people
having nervous breakdowns about pronouns
you know I think what we're seeing is a
deep unraveling that's coming about
because so many people especially young
people can't answer that question who am
I
um by resort to their native families if
you will
and this leaves a big Lacuna that has to
be filled by something and I think
increasingly it's being filled by
identity politics
getting back to what happened in the
streets of the United States there were
in 2020 over 10 000 incidents of what's
politely called unrest
in city after City
and over 500 of these devolved into what
is
impolitely called riots this is
unprecedented in American history
nothing like this has happened so where
is this coming from well of course the
conventional answer is police brutality
and racism and it's true that police
brutality uh energized a lot of people
especially young people who were already
living under the restrictions of the
pandemic Etc
this is what started it but this is not
what kept the momentum going night after
night in cities like Portland where you
would see the same young people out
there throwing things attacking the
police
this does not explain the level of sheer
emotiveness that we saw in these riots
these did not look like
civil rights protests they didn't even
look like anti-vietnam protests from
what I've seen of that footage
this was very raw primordial stuff that
was in the streets of America
and we can see that very clearly in the
sort of Street Theater that this
devolved into where people protesters
and rioters were going around into
residential neighborhoods shining lights
into people's homes as they were
sleeping or disrupting people who were
out trying to dine Outdoors
in the rage that we see in those acts I
believe uh we can see through it to a
place where people are so unhinged and
so devoid of attachment of uh Primal
attachments of their own that they are
now
taking it out on people who they
perceive to have those things that is
the deeper meaning of all that anger
spilling into residential neighborhoods
and uh attacking innocent bystanders who
had nothing to do with police brutality
or racism but were representative of a
kind of world a kind of uh order
that many young people are now having
serious trouble finding and that to me
is the deeper meaning of what we saw in
the streets we saw identity Politics as
an unstable substitute for more stable
connections to family and community
and Mary it's what I like about your
analysis as well I heard your brilliant
conversation with Christina Hoff Summers
who I have a lot of respect for as well
and in the you you talk about how
identity politics you know it's very
fashionable for people on the right to
attack people on the left with it but
actually you talk also about the rise of
the insole uh Community you talk about
the rise of white nationalism such as it
is I'm not saying it's widespread but it
certainly exists right so the idea of
identifying with a group seems to appeal
across the political Spectrum to people
and it certainly makes sense that you
know I I can feel it you know you talk
about being religious Francis and I are
both non-believers but the awareness of
the fact that people crave community and
also the the emergence of the sort of
woke thing that feels very religious in
nature it's got its inquisitions it's
got its cancel culture it's got all of
that we I mean it does seem like what
you're saying is true so I guess the
question is
all that being accepted
I mean it's not like I don't imagine
you're suggesting reversing the sexual
Revolution and disappearing the pill and
contraceptives are you
no I'm talking about renorming Society
in a more uh reasonable Direction which
we do all the time I mean human beings
do learn from mistakes and one of the
Prime examples of this is what's
happened with tobacco smoking over the
last 60 years and I say this not to
knock smokers
um but everybody knows there's been a
sea change everybody knows that Decades
of evidence about the negative effects
of this substance
um made it easier for people to quit and
made it
um more stigmatized than it had been
tobacco use indoors is very stigmatized
at least in the United States
and all of this was the result of
empirical evidence eventually filtering
down to individual decisions and that I
think is what needs to happen with the
sexual Revolution because the costs of
it are not only you know on the
individual level of romance and not only
in our increasingly untethered
um woke politics
but also
the shrinkage of the family and the
fracturing of the family has raised the
cost of the welfare state Across the
Western World the state has had to come
in and be that substitute daddy the
state simultaneously bankrolls the uh
broken family
um and and and has to so these are
pretty major consequences that affect
the most advanced economies of the world
in every single country uh we're not
talking about
private consensual transactions here and
that's what's really
ironic to me in the long run is that
everybody says this is only about
private decisions right sexual matters
are completely off the table we can't
talk about this stuff it's all private
and it's all about consent
and yet nothing has done as much to
transform our world as this revolution
has socially politically uh as and as I
mentioned in Primal screams you know
psychologically and otherwise so it's
something we probably ought to look at
it seems to me
[Music]